T night might be for the future not
actually for now because you know you
have to get you have to get better to
understand this information you what is
he's got a very nice form but I'm going
to tell something for him but in the
future when he goes towards third day
it'll be valuable so let's
okay so what he is is he's very precise
so what he's this determin determin in
such a word is he's determining exactly
where he's going to put him
down and what you and that means you're
actually the aggressor because you're
determining that Scott's only going to
stop there and you're going to go down
there so as you go
further you
FL I didn't determine where he went I I
of enjoyed the RO and then the end of
the
RO so it sort of travels to its maximum
depth so what you're doing now is
perfectly right for your level and if
you were doing what I'm showing you that
would be I'd be telling you
off I'm trying to say look I'm not when
you look at a teacher sometimes you go
wow wow but you can't get there but at
least you can aim you know long term you
can aim for
that so I just want to show you again so
if I do this and say that that's where
going to
down then I actually become the attacker
only because I go there see he's there
he's know what I'll go
down I'm not letting it run its course
but if
I don't worry about this this happens in
C some
this give you a tap years and years gone
by we' tried over
[Music]
thatz even though ATT you you're still
going to give his
wrist so so you're doing nothing wrong
just saying that you've got to make it
so that he goes all that way turns that
way and then goes down that way if he
doesn't get all the way around to turn
see he's still going that way and I
decide to do that
I become because I stopped it before it
Flo you all
got he's got do U turn let's try again